you know I just got done with a really
cool phone call so Markiplier I may have
heard of him before God damn
God damn I came up
project in space and apparently he was
telling me that watching our quarter
Crew videos taught him how to go out and
make that project which is pretty nuts
to me if all you guys watching this
right now I feel like you're all loaded
up with knowledge about how to make
movies but you don't really know how to
apply it well I asked Mark if he'd come
in and tell us the story of how he did
apply it let's see what kind of problems
and crazy stuff he had to solve and how
he learned to do it from watching our
videos cut two a week later
foreign
[Laughter]
my name is Mark these lovely people have
invited me back into their home once
more so you've made a jump that a lot of
people try to make which is that of
filmmaking you're trying to get into
narrative filmmaking directing producing
telling stories but you are self-taught
what I wanted to do with my original
channel is I wanted to make narrative
stuff where I play all the characters
and so I'm multiplying myself that's why
it's called Markiplier such an old clone
like video reference exactly it's Mark
and multiplier together and when I
started I was actually watching a lot of
corridor videos at the time and I and I
would watch these videos over and over
again because I would see like the
special effects and the things that were
possible with making videos on YouTube
but doing it yourself and I would say to
myself this is what I want to do and I
tried really hard and I couldn't do it
but what I could do is practice making
YouTube videos and uploading by playing
games games was my backup plan solid
backup plan yeah it worked out
you're not complaining about it it
worked out but it's always been my
passion to make higher production stuff
so Mark you went from somebody who
didn't study film to watching a bunch of
videos on the internet and practicing to
full on executing a multi-hour long
narrative with full visual effects and
acting and sound and cruise and all that
kind of stuff
welcome aboard the Invincible ticket
Mark just dropped a huge project in
space basically the title says it all
you're in space with me things go wrong
because you're in space with me and uh
you have to fix it because you play the
captain
it's a narrative it has cinematography
it has VFX a lot of VFX two and a half
years ago you visited us to pick our
brains about building a first person
camera rig I love first person rigs but
getting a cinematic first person camera
rig is not easy you basically have to
invent it from scratch the objective was
to have the character of the viewer as
the captain they needed to be a lot more
personable there's a lot more
interaction you could do when they're
literally the character and they have
their hands there and they can reach out
and grab it and they can interact with
it so you imagine if this suddenly had a
hand coming out at me and then slapping
me in the face just like that
thank you head mounted rigs have been
done before in like hardcore Henry that
was a GoPro so super wide shaky and
stuff like that so there was a lot of
elements to put into it to make sure
that the experience wasn't nauseating
was still flexible like the person could
move around jump around but not in a way
that it's just wibbly wobbly camera so
we needed like a high quality camera we
actually had a monster on this thing
damn monster was like almost as big as
this guy right yeah pretty much poor
Jordan our camera operator's neck was
wearing 22 pounds every day whoa he
looks like a drop ship Gunner from like
a sci-fi film I mean pretty much right
he was throwing himself down he was
landing on the floor he was going all
over the place he was twisting running
he was basically his own stunt guy
because no other stunned person could
potentially do that stuff so we had to
figure out a way to rig it all up so
that he could be safe and still be able
to be a character
Captain
so the trick of first person and
interactive is keeping everything moving
really quickly you can't cut you have to
plan a transition with a wiper anything
like that this is actually an
opportunity for a cut so we actually cut
on that wipe over
so all this problem solving is problem
solving this happening as we're filming
every day and so you know some of our
cuts are great some of our cuts are
clearly dummy replacement shots do the
dummy shots that you do have in this
series are a lot of time is me throwing
my own dummy so it's grab me leaning
back that's still me this is where we've
gone to a new shot the captain doesn't
have me anymore but I'm kind of like off
frame I throw myself into the wall and
then I'm on the ground here I just stand
to back up as if I was just thrown nice
that dummy to to you switched there's a
term for that you know what the term is
here's a little hint which which state
did you feel maybe oh is it Texas switch
ah so it's only natural that while you
guys are coming in Austin that you would
use a Texas switch in fact it's illegal
to do it anywhere else yeah okay that's
fair that's good to know
so this is a shot that I like I wrote
and I was like I don't know if we can do
this right but that particular one it's
always simpler than you think you just
put him on a dolly all he has to do is
make contact with my throat I lift
myself up and then everything moves
around it's just like so fun to have
this like mixture of ideas it's a
Melting Pot of everyone's best ideas and
you just like throw every idea in we'll
filter out the ones that don't work they
may not even be bad they just don't work
and then we'll just like be left of the
product it's as good as it could be yeah
that's great I mean that's such a good
attitude
unbelievable
deserve what's coming to you
this is actually an interesting frame to
stop on because it's like the big
tragedy of VFX this shot is not hard
right you know this yeah right this shot
I mean the model making the model was
obviously detailed stuff yeah nothing is
going to buy it setting it up to explode
the actual effects itself but this is a
put the model there set it up to explode
and hit go right right everyone about
this one who's like oh it looks so cool
right it looks great but the actual work
comes in the other ones with comping and
tracking it's like motion this is a
static explosion Mark where are you
getting all this terms from cracking
explosions uh learned it from you and
everyone else on the couch so you know I
learned everything I know about VFX from
you guys I didn't go into these videos
that you were making with the VFX
artists react specifically thinking that
I was going to learn anything I watched
them because they were entertaining and
interesting an insight into movies which
I enjoy but I haven't watched the
website ones at Corridor digital.com
where you can see bonus behind scenes
and extra content why not check it out
today Lincoln description
[Laughter]
first stop the warp core the heart and
soul of the ship with this shot here in
the opening there's a VFX plasma ball
but this entire ceiling is a replacement
right the reason this is here is because
we talked about this what we needed to
convey we need to give the ship a sense
of size that we did not have on set
right because the set is very small to
give it a sense of scale you can create
set extensions like for this we only
have so much budget for a reactor room
and the room itself this is maybe like
10 feet by 12 feet not big but you use
VFX to create a set extension and then
you create a story excuse of how I
picked it up it's about to blow the
actual person puts a shutter down you
have a story reason to not see it and
also we literally never open that window
we are looking at that wall exactly
because that wall is not expensive
that's a cheap wall and I like a cheap
wall
I'm impressed by something I just
noticed right here where you're talking
about this it's not just the technical
side of things but you understand the
function and storytelling and the
function in production whereas like okay
when you make the ship look big from a
story point of view because our set is
not that big also we need to do this in
the beginning and look at something that
we never look at again because then we
don't have to spend the money doing this
effect shot over and over and over and
so not only do you understand what you
need for the story you understand what
you need for the production and you're
bringing both of those together learn
that from your videos I think of the
portal one
you ready check this out let's do this
it's like all the craziness and the
planning behind it was like but it's all
a tool to tell what you're trying to
tell and it's trying to illustrate
something the VFX is a tool to help tell
the story it is pretty but it's not just
pretty
hi I'm coming to you live from space to
talk about the other kind of space the
square kind that's right if you're in
the market for a website you gotta build
it but you don't quite got the chops to
hire an entire web dev team guess what
they have you covered Squarespace is a
whole bunch of great features for
example our website quarterdigital.com
you know that it's a subscription-based
service turns out you can do the same
thing on Squarespace you don't actually
have to have a whole team build it for
you custom who would have thought so
that's pretty cool also you got a whole
bunch of great traffic and analytics
which are key to knowing what's going on
with your website and what makes it
effective you can think of running a
website like running a spaceship for
example you need a good crew and then
you'll be able to do important things
one on a Squarespace website you can
have multiple contributors working
together there to make the site as good
as it could possibly be Squarespace also
has great integration of video so you
want to embed some YouTube videos or
video videos and make your website all
snazzy and move well you can do just
that also you own all the content that
you upload to Squarespace so you can
rest easy there you can go to
squarespace.com right now for a free
trial and when you're ready to drop some
actual cash and make this thing happen
well if you go to squarespace.com code
or crew you can get 10 off your next
website or domain purchase all right I'm
uh
I'm getting close to the planet that I'm
heading to so gotta sign off see you
guys later
you guys did a lot of videos about three
scans so I actually asked about 3D scans
before we did this I mean this is how we
were able to get the CG double so lights
go out I do a little motion and then
that's full CG double put some motion
blur on that I'm out in the darkness was
that your idea to do the lights out gig
or is the VFX supervisor it was actually
the lighting team
watch it
we wouldn't want to have an accident now
would we so we have this joke where we
do a head replacement as
but it's effective right it doesn't need
to be perfect and this is why I was
talking with the VFX supervisor is like
is this possible and I was like yeah if
you don't mind a little Jank to it and
so I'm like I'm good with Jank I love
Jank I mean he's changing perspective
and Lighting on and everything yeah just
having Lighting in there in general like
does so much psychologically Anchor It
All right so on the topic of Jank like
you know no matter the budget there's
always something janky on a film set
you're just trying to hide it it's like
what was an example of that here
these doors these [ __ ] doors so you
can push the button or it's motion
sensor and it'll open right they open
slow and on a spaceship when we're
running out there we can't go like yeah
the reactor's about to blow
it's like a grocery store one right so
we ended up actually ripping out all the
motors that we paid 600 bucks per door
and had a guy
oh there's many times in here where I am
doing it because the captain will go
past me I will lean down pull the door
open and then I will go around in the
door and come out the door I'll be like
what happened wow that's literally how
we did it and then you'll see Isaac the
ad doing it you'll see like a lot of the
group people doing it you know just like
whoever was there
bless my stars was it the nightmare
about the spaceship again
I look at this and I I can pick it apart
of things that I know I can do better
because I learned what did you learn
after you made this project as a
director there's a realization that
there are people in other departments
that will know it better than you ever
will and you need to trust them the
other thing that I learned similarly to
learning about VFX learning enough about
every department so that you know when
you're asking them to do something it's
not an unreasonable request and you have
an expectation of how much time that
request takes therefore you're only
asking them of things that you know can
be done in the day you as a director are
integrating with people and you're
trying to communicate what's in your
head which they cannot imagine so you
have to be as clear and as concise as
possible yeah directing is like one of
those things where like you don't quite
know what the job is until you start
doing it and even then there's a
constant question of like is this what
all the other directors do or is it just
me assuming that this is what all
directors do I'm just you know dancing
the part really being a YouTuber kind of
prepped me for it because I only work
with people that I like working with and
who are kind and nice and able to do the
work that needs to be done and when you
get on a film set every single person is
like that it's a dream they love they're
doing this because they love it and it's
passionate as all right so you get to be
in a room full of people that just
really want to make your vision come
true that is a beautiful feeling so you
can't betray that trust you just can't
the year is 2023. and markiplier gets
his first computer from his Pappy he
sits down he wants to make a YouTube
channel what would you recommend a
YouTuber starting out do in this day and
age oh fresh-faced pimples everywhere a
bowl cut
nerd straight up Virgin
in a lot of ways it's a journey of trial
and error right so you have your first
project and it's garbage always it's
garbage it's so bad realize that making
videos is the start of a never-ending
journey of looking inward at yourself
and measuring of what you're capable of
doing against an arena of people that
have been doing it for years it's like
any creative medium there are people in
that field that are better than you are
at that moment and that can be crippling
that can be devastating understand that
creation is not a comparative against
those people it's comparative against
yourself what you make next is only
comparable to what you made before even
if you haven't made anything is only
comparable to what you made before which
is nothing therefore you have literally
nothing to lose by starting you can not
fail just by making your first one I
literally wouldn't be here if you hadn't
started making videos
there may have been other YouTube
channels that helped along the way but
the original ideas came from seeing your
unbelievably impressive even to this day
videos you put out there on the internet
I'm sure there's a lot of people out
there that would not be here if you
hadn't decided to make videos with Sam
early on all these people that are part
of court or I've always said this to my
friends and people that I work with like
inspiration is the most valuable
currency if you can Inspire someone to
do something they can move the mountains
so if you want to be inspired go check
out in space part one came out a few
weeks ago from when the studio is
dropping in part two probably just came
out it's really cool there's nothing
else quite like it it feels like you're
both playing a game and watching a movie
at the same time it's really cool it is
you going out there and doing something
creative and fully like yourself while
also acknowledging all the other art
forms that are around it I really
enjoyed it actually thanks man all right
so taking a little cue from in space
here you can go on your own little
Adventure you can decide if you want to
subscribe or if you have subscribed or
if you didn't subscribe or not
subscribed well your two options are
here on the screen who knows maybe
they're both really cool maybe one's a
punishment go check it out Mark thanks
so much for joining us thank you